-Ronnie, welcome to the show.
I'm so happy to --
We hung out maybe a month ago
in London
and we had
the greatest time ever.
You were so funny.
You're the life of the party.
-So is he. He's like this
all day long, you know.
-Am I too high-energy?
-I went for dinner with him,
and I had to have
a lay-down first.
-Yeah. This is actually true.
We did the interview.
-Yeah.
-Global interview.
We were talking about
"Hackney Diamonds,"
which is finally out
this Friday.
And we get to dinner,
and you're not there,
and we go,
"Where's Ronnie and Sally?"
And your wife sent a picture.
She goes,
"Yeah, Ronnie's taking a nap."
And there's you taking a nap.
-I had to in order to
stay up all night with him.
But, yeah,
that's a Rolling Stone blanket
made of T-shirts
that otherwise would get lost.
I think it was a great idea.
-It's kind of a brilliant idea.
These are all Rolling Stones --
I go, "Do you sleep
with your swag?"
And you were like, "No.
I get all these T-shirts
and all this stuff and I go,
'What to do with it?'"
So you made it into a quilt.
-Yeah, well, it's, like,
lamb's wool-lined T-shirts.
And it's, like, so warm.
-It's super comfy. I love it.
Let's talk about the album.
Here we go.
It's been almost 20 years
since --
-It's the first time
I seen one opened up.
-Is that right?
-...shrink wrap.
Wow!
-I'm honored!
-Hey, everybody!
Welcome to the album.
I'm really honored.
-How does it -- How does it feel
to have a new
Rolling Stones album?
-Well, I can say
it's about time.
-Yes. Of course.
20 years is just about
the right amount of time.
-It feels so exciting
because I'm excited
about every track on it.
-Yes.
-Every track has got
a different thing to say
and a different direction.
-I mean, we can talk
about things now.
We weren't even allowed
to talk about everything.
You do a great song
with Lady Gaga,
"Sweet Sounds of Heaven,"
that is unbelievable.
And Stevie Wonder.
-Yes.
-And Elton John and --
-Yeah, but Stevie Wonder
and Lady are on
"Sweet Sound of Heaven,"
which you may have already
heard because the only ones --
only tracks
to be released so far
are "Angry"
and "Sweet Sound of Heaven."
And I'm just blown away
with them.
I mean, to be in the studio
with that genius Stevie Wonder.
-Yes, but which one are you
looking forward to the audience
hearing, like,
that aren't those two?
Is it the --
-"Whole Wide World."
-Yeah, that's a great --
-It's a great up-tempo...
♪ Da da da da da da da da ♪
-Yes. Yeah. I love it. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Good. That's good.
-You're gonna love that.
-You're gonna love that one.
-And for the other side
of the coin,
there's a country kind of
flavored song
called "Dreamy Skies"
where I get to play
a little slide and mix things.
It's very country.
-I should mention, also,
this was made after
the passing of Charlie Watts,
who is obviously your brother
and your band member,
one of the greatest drummers.
-Yeah, well, some things
are beyond our control,
and losing Charlie
was one of those things.
But before he did pass,
he said to me and to the band --
Because I was the last one
to see him in his hospital room.
And he said, "Just make sure
that you get Steve Jordan
to cover for me.
And when I get well,
I can come, you know."
But he said, "Until then,
please make sure
you have Steve Jordan."
And Steve is like a rocket ship
behind you. It's so fantastic.
-And so you got Steve.
-You know Steve.
-Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah.
We love Steve. That's wild.
But you got to do two songs --
Charlie plays on two songs
on this album.
-Yeah.
And Andrew Watt, our producer,
a magic producer.
-Andrew Watt, by the way --
-Pulled this out of the hat.
-What a great job he did.
-Yeah, well, he did.
He had some wonderful
little ideas, like,
"Okay, let's use the drum track
of Charlie
on 'Live by the Sword,'
and I'll call in Bill Wyman
to get the bass."
And so in Charlie's absence,
we got the band --
the original band back together.
-Original Rolling Stones. Yeah.
When you came
onto the Rolling Stones,
that was '75, '76?
-Yeah. It was '74. My first solo
album with "Shirley."
-Oh, yeah.
You do know the song! A-ha!
Yeah, you're just
playing with me. Yeah.
-In fact, it didn't sound
anything like it.
That's the funk version.
-That's the fun part.
That's what makes it fun.
But, so,
you come into the Stones.
They're already
the Rolling Stones.
Did you -- Were you a fan
of the band? Did you --
-Yeah.
Ever since I was at college.
-I used to race home to see them
on this show called
"Ready Steady Go!"
and "Thank Your Lucky Stars."
All the English TV shows we had.
And I'd say,
"That's my kind of music.
I'm going to be in that band!"
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And they called you and said,
"Do you want to join the band?"
And you're like,
"Yeah, of course."
-Yeah, but a series
of wonderful coincidences
being in the right place
at the right time
made it happen for me.
You know, it was just --
-Was it Keith --
Was it Keith
who you were friends with?
There's a picture
of you and Keith, by the way,
This is 1979, I believe.
But was it Keith who --
I mean, what else could you be
besides rock stars
in this photo?
I mean, come on.
This is just legendary.
-And that's on board our plane,
as well.
-Yes. Of course it is.
Why not? Yeah, exactly.
So you get together, you play
with the Rolling Stones.
You're just legendary.
What a great career.
And then this album comes out
and kind of --
Can we talk about this song?
-"Bite My Head Off."
-That's wonderful. We just
rehearsed that yesterday.
We've been doing a little bit
of rehearsing to see
how these songs translate live,
and they're really cooking.
-Can you tell people who is
a special guest on that song?
-Paul McCartney --
his big dream -- said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A Beatle is on
the Rolling Stones album!
A Beatle is on
What is going on?!
-Yeah. Well, the song goes...
♪ Bah bah bah bah bah bah bah
bah bah bah dah dah dah dah ♪
♪ Bite my head off ♪
Right?
And Paul --
he was so blown away.
He was a bit like a schoolboy,
you know?
A kid in a toy shop, you know?
-Yeah.
-And he loved it.
He said, "My dream!"
-Really?
-He said, "A Beatle gets to play
on a Rolling Stones album!"
Yeah, he was really knocked out.
Yeah.
-It's so good.
Wait till you hear this album.
It's getting great reviews,
so congratulations on that.
-Yeah.
I also want to mention,
by the way, that -- I know
everyone probably knows this,
but maybe if you don't,
you're an amazing painter.
You really are a great artist.
-Thanks. I've been painting
since I was little.
-Yeah. Was your family into --
-Yeah, my two older brothers.
I grew up eight years
behind Ted,
ten years behind Art.
-Great name.
-And all of our initials
spell ART -- Art, Ron, and Ted.
Anyway, so the thing is...
-Wow.
-If they --
They were musicians, too.
So if they played, I would play.
And if they painted,
I would paint.
And it just stuck with me
all the years.
-I figured I'd show
just a couple just to see...
-I just copied that.
That's a tribute to Van Gogh.
-Yeah. It's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And this is a tribute
to Delacroix,
one of my favorite
French painters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is -- You're so talented.
I can't -- And this one...
-This is a little tribute
to "Angry."
-Yeah.
-It's called
"Barcelona Diamonds."
-Yeah. Barcelona.
Go to RonnieWood.com and
check out more of Ronnie's art.
I'm just so happy
that I know you,
and I'm happy that you came on.
I know you don't really do
talk shows.
This means so much to me.
And to meet your family
all backstage.
The most beautiful family.
And your daughters are gorgeous.
And I just want to say
thank you so much
and congrats on the record.
-You were so nice to them.
You made them feel so warm.
-The best. This is Ronnie Wood,
ladies and gentlemen!
"Hackney Diamonds"
is out this Friday.
-Thank you!
-This Friday!
We'll be right back
with Sam Heughan.
Stick around, everybody!